other than the fact that this freaking
hand thing seems to work like on any
given negative that's the meme it's like
any time he does that every time a
dinosaur shows up i just half expect
that these dinosaurs are always like
whoa what what is whoa whoa this guy's
got something else i've never seen this
one counter
he's never met before yeah they're
always like
you got the hands up let's see what this
guy has to say
every time
[Music]
what is happening there reject nation
greg and john back at it at the cinemark
we just watched harassed world dominion
but this time we watched it in a very
specific format which is d-box they
wanted us to watch it in d-box and for a
reason i mean it sincerely we even
watched top gun maverick in d-box as
well watching jurassic world dominion in
d-box i do think is one of the absolute
best ways to experience this film it's
been a while since we've done anything
of this type of more immersive theater
experience but they have completely
fine-tuned they have the mastered the
timing and the movement to be in sync
with the audio and video of the movie it
does make it more immersive it feels
much more calculated it doesn't just
feel like repetitive go through the
motions of what it is it's super duper
in sync and i loved it also that you can
control the intensity because sometimes
it could be a little too much for
certain people and that was fun to kind
of mess around with from time to time
during the movie so guys this is a great
way to experience jurassic world
dominion especially with the kind of
visuals and camera movement this film
has so go to cinemark.com get yourself
some tickets today and find the nearest
d-box near you because it's absolutely
worth it now how was the movie itself
though as a whole let's talk about it if
you've seen our trailer reactions you
know
we were both
very much looking forward to this film
just a quick recap on thoughts and
feelings of the jurassic world franchise
specifically i really like the first
jurassic world movie a lot i think it's
a fun roller coaster all right there's
the original jurassic park and there's
everything afterwards
but jurassic world one i think it's a
lot of fun jurassic world fallen kingdom
i loathe that film i know you like it a
tiny bit i like it more than you i like
it more than jurassic world honestly i
load that film but jurassic world
dominion i was very much excited by the
trailers for this because it seemed like
they had something so much more
different to explore something so much
more new as opposed to being locked off
at like an island again or some [ __ ]
like that this would take place around
the world essentially you would see a
world where humans and dinosaurs are
learning to co-exist with one another
that's the world this movie is so this
film basically has two plots
there's a lot of plots there's like 45
plots of this movie but there's too many
spots you can boil it down to all right
so the first main plot is you have owen
chris pratt bryce dallas howard claire
and and do you guys remember clone girl
from the last movie how could you forget
well if you did forget don't worry
they're gonna recap the [ __ ] out of it
for you there is a last time on jurassic
world if ever i've seen one on this
movie they're gonna remind you to the
chord this is your first time don't even
sweat so in that plot line they have to
keep the clone girl you know separate
from the world because everyone's after
her she's we need her dna and while
they're living out in the wilderness
there's blue blue's back and blue has a
baby beta beta i loved this dinosaur all
right i love blue's always been the best
part of jurassic world franchise and
beta the baby blue love baby blue here
all of those plushies being sold right
now so part of this world now is that
there's a lot of poaching going on baby
blue gets kidnapped clone girl gets
kidnapped owen and claire have to
venture across the globe to go find them
rescue them
second plot which i won't go into too
much detail about because the trailers
actually didn't reveal much about it but
it's heavily heavily heavily focused on
alan grant sam neil and laura duren's
ellie sadler they are such a predominant
part of this film it's not like they're
just a cameo and that's kind of a cool
thing that i thought they did with it
because you did have two different films
in here where it's like jeff goldblum's
not featured as much as i'm still an
important supporting character but not
featured as much there's basically
something with science corporate batty
and they have to go stop it stop that
you're gonna go stop it
that's that's the plot and then
eventually you'll see these these two
plots you know converge together into
one what i'll say is that in the first
20 minutes of this film i was completely
on board for it it was exactly what the
trailers were omitting to me and now
watching it play out where it had a
sense of awareness of kind of how fun
this could all be a little cheesy but a
really good like fleshing out of here's
what the world is like now and how
difficult and challenging it is for the
dinosaurs and humans to coexist with one
another it really had a good handle on
it in a way that was really entertaining
to watch i was all for it this one had a
different setting in the sense that it
wasn't just one setting at least for the
first half of this movie it wasn't just
one setting it was it's everything
exploring the the world and it's a
little cheesy but i'm enjoying it i'm
i'm for it from what i'm about to say
you'll probably go isn't that what you
expected from the trailers though isn't
that what you kind of expect when you
watch this movie i don't understand how
that's a criticism that's what i want
greg that's when i saw the trailers the
problem is it becomes
numbing it becomes a little tone deaf
yeah there's a rinse repeat cycle of
like okay here's a few lines either
pertaining vaguely to an interesting
idea that's plot oriented or here's a
couple of kind of boilerplatey character
dialogue bits then oh wait there's a
threat moment of suspense to pay homage
to the fact that these used to be
monster movies and now we're doing a big
old action scene because we just found
out the next location and what's between
us in that location an action scene
pretty much spirals down a cacophony
hole after a while yeah and you get so
used to it it's never scary first off
because of the fact that everyone who's
put in these situations is often either
the same people over and over and over
again or it's just you know returning
main characters so i'm not gonna say who
lives or dies by the end of this film
but for the run time of this movie
you're pretty much guaranteed that uh
they're probably gonna be fine so it's
not even scary it's not that exciting
and there's not much tension due to the
fact that you know there's there's
safety in plot armor this is basically
their job now is to be in these
situations yeah as far as the returning
characters go what i'll say is that like
alan grant weirdly was sam neil was just
always a pleasure to watch and it's nice
seeing him and laura dern have a bunch
of scenes together they still have great
chemistry but alan grant ultimately felt
unnecessary to this movie like he he
just kind of grumped his way throughout
the whole film yeah and it felt like it
was going to arch into something or he
would do something super vital and
important but he doesn't laura dern
though i thought she was excellent i
think laura dern out of the returning
cast members is the best one of the of
the three jeff goldblum
was very fascinating because
here's the weird part about jeff
goldblum he was making the theater laugh
at the same time and i heard other
people saying this too he really didn't
seem like he had his heart in this film
and it seemed like he didn't give a [ __ ]
throughout it
and that's part of what made it funny
because there's no must go faster must
go faster you know uh jeff goldblum it's
just kind of mocking the material in a
lot of ways yeah there's a weird quality
to these characters where i feel like
especially with the jurassic world
movies to me and especially with
characters like owen and claire there's
a quality where even though they're
played by the same actors and
technically they're carrying on the same
storyline they always feel like they
could be any two people and i feel like
that almost sort of starts to seep into
characters like jeff goldblum who has
appeared in multiple sequels and in the
previous one he's only in there for one
scene so i feel like out of everyone it
is a little bit of a bummer he shows up
so it's fun to watch him but it is a
little bit like you're used to this i
can tell well the setup of this movie
does have a great debate and it does try
to like bookend it with it of
how do we co-exist like create this
fictional world and then let's have
conversations about it let's have a
debate about it but halfway through this
movie it essentially just becomes
another jurassic park sequel again where
it takes place at this isolated location
there's bad scientist guy that's it it's
like just setups of like encountering
dinosaurs it's so repetitive in the way
it goes like they just keep stumbling
into the same setup like john described
and the same type of like they they mix
it up they're don't get me wrong there
are some really cool shots and i really
feel like colin chavarro really cared i
feel like he really put his all into
crafting these action scenes but the
emotion underneath is just not there and
it's not in the script either and unlike
jurassic world one for me and for a lot
of people that was at least
fun even though there's more of it it's
not anywhere near as fun it actually
feels like it takes itself even more
serious this time around and it feels
like if you trimmed out 20 minutes of
action and maybe
yeah and a couple of plots and maybe
shifted some of that focus to our
classic returning characters and our
recent returning characters you could
have had something that is as fun as it
wants to be and as satisfying as it
wants to be it's like the first jurassic
world movie was commenting on it's like
it almost gets boring because you're
like i i get it dinosaurs and chaos cool
give me something to care about with the
characters i am happy to see back well
it's kind of crazy how chris pratt has
become progressively more boring in
these films he is like dead on the
inside in this film he is not
entertaining in the slightest bit bryce
dallas howard i think they try to make
her character better here and i like
this is weird because i like them both
as actors and i like bryce ella's heart
a lot as a director especially but man
they they have no chemistry there are a
couple new characters who are who are a
lot of fun there's this pilot girl who
you've seen in the trailers when they're
on the plane and then the pterodactyl
comes flying down or i don't know if
it's pterodactyl but whatever that girl
she is great
great i was like she should be the main
character she should she's great yeah
her and the guy who's the assistant to
jeff goldblum was both great and and her
especially her especially and when she
showed up i was like oh no i could
easily see how this character could be
written totally obnoxiously she won me
in every moment
she elevates it if you're gonna watch it
you're already gonna watch it you
already kind of know what you're walking
into i was a little let down by the fact
that the first 20 minutes seemed to be
this is it this is the film this is what
the trailers are this is good but then
it just becomes typical jurassic park
sequel and that's probably the biggest
letdown of it is not that interesting
whatsoever it's like a lot of just
science mumbo jumbo and some of it is
based in realism but it's there's no
impulse no personality or passion behind
the script to really make that stuff
sing no it's just information being
thrown at you that actually
yeah and two if you wanted what the
trailers were giving us which is like
we're gonna see these sweeping shots
almost sometimes with no dialogue or no
humans whatsoever there are moments
little moments where the movie does do
that just goes into these little visual
sequences but they are not at all like
the trailers would have you expect like
you do descend pretty fast into
blockbuster action cacophony and i feel
like the thing that is kind of stepping
on its own feet about this franchise is
the fact that they want to force it to
be an action movie instead of like you
can get a lot of action out of monster
movie aesthetics but i feel like they go
full-on action movie again with just
that one little beat of suspense to pay
service and it does diminish the returns
of the thrills of the movie across the
board that's our thoughts on it i
genuinely mean it that d-box does make
it a better experience yes right and
some decent ideas at the core yeah yeah
and if not d-box for this d-box or
something else because like top gun
maverick is great film and a great
uh but jurassic world dominion
yeah pretty let down by it what do you
guys want from this franchise uh did you
watch it did you like it leave your
thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell thank you to d
box and cinemark
well uh we'll talk with you all soon